[Music]
on this Monday night the Niagara
Region's State of Emergency the risk for
residents and First Responders it's very
scary plus The Big Box store that became
a refuge a tropical vacation ending with
an enormous headache
of sun wing passengers with no flight
back to Canada China does a 180 on its
zero covid policy the dwindling
restrictions and Rising infections plus
the final frontier in the Forefront We
rise together back to the moon and
Beyond Canada's critical contributions
to space exploration
global national with Donna Frieza
reporting tonight
good evening and thanks for joining us
Ontario's Niagara region is about to
enter its third day of a state of
emergency thousands of people are still
without power and weather warnings are
in effect in areas already hard hit by a
fierce storm the treacherous conditions
don't seem to be going away anytime soon
forcing people to bundle up and hunker
down Sean O'Shea Is in Ridgeway Ontario
tonight good evening Sean look through
the Dig outs in this dangerous winter
storm will take days in part because
where we we are it's still snowing for
many people they haven't had power since
last week cars and trucks abandoned
drivers who couldn't move anymore
because of intense snow and high winds
leading to a state of emergency here
are extensive power outages in
communities like this one there's little
or no heat it's very scary people are
trying to reach out to their loved ones
down here we can't get a hold of people
around us the crippling weather started
Friday
by Saturday had gotten worse while I was
stuck in the middle of it trying to find
somebody who's in a vehicle accident
here and they're not sure where that
person is near zero visibility for hours
was too dangerous even for First
Responders who said they couldn't
guarantee help for anyone who got stuck
in the blinding snow highways were
closed and a group of stranded Shoppers
spent two days including Christmas at
this Fort Erie Walmart store so we
served a Christmas dinner for 11 people
on Saturday night at the Walmart at
Walmart one of the busiest border
crossings with the United States is
still closed the Peace Bridge is off
limits across the river in Buffalo
they're calling it the worst storm ever
the governor puts it this way we are in
a war this is a war with Mother Nature
crippling weather that some Canadians
compared to the great blizzard of 1977
the snow is piled high in front of this
120 year old Pharmacy in the village and
as bad as the weather's been many are
still grateful we feel very blessed that
we had a generator we were able to keep
things going but it's hard when you
can't get to other people that may need
it one of the biggest struggles for
people is Communications one person said
they haven't had phone they haven't had
internet they haven't had television
they haven't had anything for days they
don't really know what's going on me too
thanks Sean
some Canadian Travelers were able to
escape the nasty weather that hit here
at home because they were in Mexico
there's just one problem there's sun
wing flights back to Canada have been
canceled some customers say they feel
trapped and as cabbie Mali Theron
reports they don't know when they'll be
coming home
we are trying to do something for these
two peoples the gift of family is all
that Lydia matte sought this holiday
season she was supposed to fly with her
daughter to Punta Cana from Saskatoon on
December 21st where her mother and her
daughter would meet for the first time
but like so many Travelers those plans
changed they just allowed let us know
that the flight will be delayed for
December 22nd they returned for their
sun wing flight on the 22nd only to find
out the flight was pushed yet again to
the 23rd and when they arrived at the
airport the next day there is nobody
there there is nobody to talk to there's
no nothing to be done yeah
the same situation for 100 stuck in
Mexico sleeping on Airport floors as
days of flight delays turned into
cancellations many turning to social
media to vent their frustrations one
person saying they've been stuck for
five days with no response from the
airline another user asking anyone in
this group from flight wg361 from Punta
Cana back to Saskatoon hoping to get
answers from other stranded passengers
that chain ongoing from the last two
days in a statement sunwink says in part
as a result of severe winter weather in
Vancouver this week which has stranded
several planes and crew we unfortunately
had to cancel some southbound flights
from other western Canada airports
including Saskatoon they go on to say
customers with direct bookings would
have been notified and those with
canceled flights will receive a refund
within 30 days
mate just wants answers I really ask
these uh big guys at some link to
understand that canceling a flight is
not just an easy thing and has much more
impact
on people cavi malitarian Global News
Saskatoon
air travel has also been disrupted by
the pandemic and China will be lifting
covid-19 quarantine and testing
requirements for international arrivals
starting on January 8th Beijing is now
navigating a sharp pivot away from its
strict zero coveted policy and as
Redmond Shannon reports it appears to be
resulting in Rising cases and A Renewed
concern about what's next
this is not a scene from December 2020
before widespread covid-19 vaccination
it is from China in December 2022
hospitals and funeral homes struggling
to deal with China's largest ever surge
of covid-19 cases the hospital is just
overwhelmed from top to bottom so you
know the the ER filled up with people
the financial times reports that Beijing
officials privately estimate 250 million
Chinese people contracted the virus in
the first 20 days of December I'm
exhausted this ER doctor tells Chinese
State tv even the much lower official
numbers of cases and deaths are now
unknown China has simply stopped
publishing figures and it has said a
higher bar for what constitutes a covert
death the wave comes just weeks after
China began to dismantle its strict zero
covet strategy first introduced almost
three years ago the changes following a
series of protests from a very weary
population president Xi Jinping has
asked officials to do whatever is
feasible to save lives in this wave but
beijing's 180 on zero kovid continues a
pace on January 8 hotel quarantine will
end for passengers arriving on
international flights China's full
vaccination rate is high but less so
among seniors and studies indicate its
domestic vaccines are much less
effective at preventing serious cases
last week the World Health Organization
said it believes China is looking at
registering a western mRNA vaccine we
would certainly encourage that kind of
work the true long-term impact of
China's strategy will only become clear
in time right now many Chinese people
are dealing with concerns and fears many
of us first faced more than two years
ago Redmond Shannon Global News London
to the war in Ukraine now where the
conflict could be shifting from the
battlefield to the negotiating table
Russian President Vladimir Putin says
he's ready for talks to end the assault
Ukraine and the West though are
skeptical about his intentions and as
Mackenzie gray explains Putin admits not
all of his allies are on the same page
about the war
they're some of the only friends
Vladimir Putin has left leaders are
former Soviet States media in Saint
Petersburg on the 31st anniversary of
the fall of the Soviet Union
but even friendly countries seem to be
concerned with Putin's approach to
Ukraine and the message is getting
through
we have to admit unfortunately that
disagreements are emerging also between
members about how to maintain security
and stability within the region
when Ally Putin can count on Alexander
lukashenko the Bella Russian president
has recently approved a flurry of
military activity leading Western
countries to believe they could join the
war in Ukraine soon
in response ukrainians have stepped up
training practicing to stop a potential
attack at the Belarus Ukraine border
similar to an unsuccessful Russian
attempt in the early days of the war and
while Ukrainian soldiers keep preparing
on the battlefield the idea of the peace
formula is twofold the odds of a
negotiated end of the war are increasing
the Ukrainian foreign minister outlining
a new plan for a peace Summit in
February the United Nations could be the
best venue for holding this uh this
Summit because this is not about making
a favor to a certain country this is
really about bringing everyone on board
the one catch Dimitri kuleba says Russia
would first need to face prosecution for
war crimes at an international court
before they could be invited Ukraine is
also calling on the U.N to have Russia
removed as a permanent member of the
security Council arguing the idea was
already being discussed in diplomatic
circles it's only a matter of time when
the actions of the Russian Federation
will destroy the entire U.N system the
Ukrainian foreign Ministry says
Ukraine's hoping the United Nations
Secretary General will help moderate the
talks but there's no word from the UN if
they're willing to fulfill that role but
more importantly nithu there's no word
from Russia on if they're willing to
accept the Ukrainian invitation
Mackenzie gray in Ottawa thanks
Mackenzie it has now been one year and
three months since the last federal
election and half of Canadians want to
head back to the polls next year that's
according to a new ipsis poll conducted
exclusively for Global News the survey
also found just over half of Canadians
want Justin Trudeau to step down as
liberal leader in 2023 only one quarter
believes he will as for approval ratings
NDP leader jagmeet Singh is the most
popular at 53 percent Trudeau is next
followed by conservative leader Pierre
pauliev
Iran's doctors in danger coming up how
they're putting their lives on the line
and the Canadians trying to help them
[Music]
protests have now eclipsed the 100-day
mark in Iran making them the longest
running anti-government protests since
the country's Islamic revolution in
1979. it's believed hundreds have been
killed including doctors treating the
most severely injured [ __ ] mostahedi
spoke with one Vancouver doctor working
to help her Iranian colleagues and a
warning this story contains disturbing
details
mourners grieving the death of Dr Ida
rossami
a 36 year old Tehran physician who was
treating injured Iranians fighting for
their freedoms on the street
she was reportedly killed by the regime
tortured with injuries to her genitalia
and had her eye pulled out
Iranians wounded by the Islamic
Republic's forces apparently avoiding
treatment at hospitals for fear of being
detained prosecuted or killed
[Music]
it's hard to watch please don't arrest
doctors please let them do their job but
now it has gone to don't kill them
don't torture them Vancouver Dr kataya
navardi and a network of doctors
throughout Canada are trying to help
amplify the voices of medics in Iran
whose lives are in danger for fulfilling
an oath as clinics and hospitals become
the latest Battleground as a parent
as a daughter
I I can't understand I can't imagine the
amount of pain that these people have
gone through all these parents you know
seeing their loved ones bodies
and and tortured a Montreal woman who
was a dentist in Iran has created a
database in conjunction with her sources
inside Iran to track Iranian Health Care
Professionals who have been arrested
kidnapped and killed so far I mean
you're sure the death of at least five
Healthcare professionals there are two
doctors one nurse and two medical
students
fatty says Iranian Health Care
Professionals always have to be on guard
the regime's security forces she says
demanding names and details on anyone
seeking treatment for wounds that could
have been received in demonstrations
their informants and you can never know
who are these informants are they
patients or so-called patients are they
your colleagues are they the managers
you don't know even during the world
wars an unspoken rule that Medics
weren't not to be touched it's
considered a war crime under the Geneva
Convention it's an issue of humanity and
it's my my duty my responsibility as a
as a mother as a woman as a human being
and as a doctor [ __ ] Mo Shahidi Global
News
and liftoff of Artemis one out of this
world ahead Canada's astronomical role
in a Monumental year of exploring space
[Music]
2022 was Back to the Future with bigger
and better in space exploration a new
space telescope and a flight to the moon
and back more countries than ever are
venturing into the final frontier the
discoveries reveal more about the
universe and about Earth as Eric
Sorensen explains Canada has been a
central player in some of this year's
most important space missions
booster's indignation
and liftoff of Artemis one 2022 saw the
first moon shot from Cape Canaveral in
50 years rekindling the sense of awe
from the original Space Race but the
United States is no longer going solo We
rise together back to the moon and
Beyond NASA has Partners Canada and
Europe Artemis one just a Prelude to
what's coming Canadian technology will
help build the first lunar space station
and on the next Artemis flight in two
years history will be made one of these
four Canadian astronauts will fly around
the Moon Canada
second country in the world to going
into deep space
that flight will go out for again an
extended Mission circling around the
Moon testing out all kinds of systems if
there's International cooperation that
didn't exist half a century ago there's
also Fierce competition now on the lunar
playing field sure
China sent Crews to its brand new
orbiting space station this year and
China will partner with the Russians to
put their own lunar base on the moon in
a few years South Korea launched its
first lunar orbiter in August and how's
this for international diversity
carrying the ispace series 1 lunar
lander an American SpaceX rocket
transporting a Japanese lunar lander
that's carrying a United Arab Emirates
lunar rover
the first Arab moon rover says the
director of the UAE Space Program
carrying the hopes of the Arab world in
space Discovery no fewer than 10
countries have now conducted Moon
missions plus Private Industry has begun
testing lunar Technologies it's a great
day for all of our International
Partners that's a difference from 50
years ago it is the beginning of the new
beginning
and that is to explore the heavens 2022
also marks the beginning of exploring
the entire universe thanks to the most
far-reaching technology in history the
James Webb Space Telescope rocketed far
beyond the moon unfolding its sun shield
its mirrors and its infrared cameras
here too Canadians are crucial players
developing equipment to study the
atmosphere of distant planets and
pinpoint the earliest Stars being able
to look back
and be able to find those signatures of
the of elements that were created when
the universe was so young I mean that's
just really mind-blowing from its perch
one and a half million kilometers from
Earth the James Webb Space Telescope has
opened our eyes Webb is looking deeper
into space than ever before seeing light
from more than 13 billion years ago not
long after the big bang when the very
first stars were formed and look what it
found in a sliver of darkness in the
night sky Webb discovered galaxies
teeming with stars this Deep Field image
shows the most distant faintest objects
ever observed Stefan's quintet five
galaxies each possibly with billions of
stars a nebula where a star is dying the
cosmic Cliffs where stars are being born
honestly it took me a while to even
figure out what to call out in this
image there's just so much going on here
several times in the last six months I
nearly break my jaw of what I saw these
incredible images he's a thick cliche
but it's true we're turning the page on
several new chapters
um there's a planet that atmosphere
dealer the early Universe thought
formation you name it and we don't even
know what we're gonna find Webb brings
us closer to knowing how the universe
began and whether there is life on other
planets far away this is going to be
revolutionary these are incredible
capabilities that we've never had before
4. space exploration is expanding our
awareness of this planet's precarious
place in the cosmos satellites are
telling us more each year about the
atmosphere and climate change a
breakthrough came in nuclear fusion the
energy that powers the Sun May one day
sustain a cleaner Planet if we had
Fusion we could drop fossil fuels
immediately and forever just remember
fusion power has no nuclear waste to
speak of no meltdowns to worry about
protecting the planet saw the debut of a
powerful but simple Innovation against
Intergalactic threats oh my God goodness
this fall a rocket just slammed into a
tiny asteroid dimorphous deflecting its
orbit sending a million kilograms of
debris trailing behind for the first
time ever Humanity has changed the orbit
of a planetary body and for the first
time ever planetary defense didn't sound
like a job description from a Hollywood
script should all earthlings sleep a
little easier tonight as far as we can
tell our first planetary defense test
was a success yeah I think the
earthlings should sleep better
definitely I will in 2022 humans reached
for the moon and searched the distant
corners of the universe and it seems the
more we look out the more reason we have
to look back at the Earth
Eric Sorensen Global News
[Music]
[Music]
tis the season for giving and a pair of
Ontario rail workers turned best friends
is sharing their own story of giving in
hopes of inspiring others Brittany Rosen
has their story of a life-saving
donation that formed an unbreakable Bond
and uh you still owe me 20 bucks oh come
on co-workers Terry
Wesley Hussein work on trains for a
living
quite literally
literal friendship
in 2018 Hussein was diagnosed with an
aggressive form of kidney disease when I
got hit with that I was kind of a
shocker to me you know I was still
relatively a young guy yeah we're going
to go up to Grandma's for Christmas I
take kids out when Hussein couldn't find
a match for a Kidney donor stuckliss who
has twins stepped in I got a phone call
from Terry so
Terry said to me he said how you doing
bud and I was like you know what Terry
I'm kind of in the toilet you know like
we went through two people and it just
didn't happen and he said to me he said
well why didn't you ask me stocklas then
made a decision that would change his
life forever I was willing to part with
one of my kidneys and if my kids needed
another one
for sure I would still do the same thing
no hesitation Hussein and his best
friend underwent the operation in
December of 2020 just weeks before the
holidays with no visitors allowed in the
hospital due to the pandemic the pair
relied on one another mine is way better
than yours yours is bigger than thicker
and it's got It's like a zipper scars
Now remind the friends of the sacrifice
that leaves them permanently connected
you know just to have a friend like that
you know we started off as co-workers
became best friends you know what I mean
now he's my brother always felt like
brothers but when this happened this
that made it official and
we are Blood Brothers now blood brothers
that hope to
others to the gift of love this
this Brittany Rosen global
Global chip that is global national for
this Monday night I'm nitu garcha
tonight's your Canada is the BC
legislature in Victoria we love seeing
your Canada please email it to viewers
globalnational.com thanks for watching
Chris gayles will be at the anchor desk
tomorrow have a great night
thank you